hi everyone welcome back
so we've been talking about the havoc
or hankel alternative view of kootman
analysis
and how you can use that to get a
data-driven decomposition of chaotic
dynamics into
a linear system with intermittent
forcing
so this is just a recap of this this
havoc model you
have your system you measure data you
build a hankel matrix
and eigen time delay coordinates using
the singular value decomposition
and you can build a linear regression
model
in those time delay coordinates pretty
cool
so what i'm going to tell you about
right now in this little uh
short video is we're going to dive
deeper into the structure of this
regression model because it is super
cool
and i really want to show show you what
it looks like
so for the lorentz data this is actually
the the model that we get out this is
you know matlab i'm plotting the the
coefficients
um you know the color it indicates the
coefficient of this model so this is my
a matrix my b matrix
of my linear havoc model for lorenz
and this is very cool lots of neat
structure here so
a couple of things you notice right off
the bat it's sparse
and it's off diagonal okay so most of
the entries are zero the only ones that
are non-zero are these off-diagonal
entries
and they come in equal opposite pairs
right so this is kind of anti-symmetric
if you have positive here you have
negative here and so on and so forth
very cool we actually discovered this
havoc
framework when applying the uh sparse
identification of nonlinear dynamics or
cindy algorithm to the lorentz system
and time delay coordinates that's in
this paper here
and what we realized was even if you
give so this is a regression model
even if i allow my regression the
possibility of having nonlinear
interaction terms so
you know uh polynomial nonlinearities of
these v
these uh states
the cindy method picks out as the most
parsimonious model
this linear sparse highly structured
model
so even if you give it the possibility
of higher order nonlinear terms this is
the most parsimonious model
and that got us thinking about
connections with coupeman operators and
time delays and all these these neat
ideas
but really there's beautiful structure
here so other things that i find
fascinating about this
is that the
coefficients here are nearly
integer multiples of the number five
which is fascinating so this might be
4.9 and negative 4.9 you know 9.9 a
negative 9.9
14.9 and negative 14 finite really close
to integer multiples 5 10 15 20
25 30 and so on and so forth very close
like eerily
similar and they also have this
interesting alternating pattern where
if i look at this lower diagonal term
you have
positive positive positive positive
negative positive positive positive
negative
positive positive negative positive so
four then one then three then one then
two then one then one
i mean this could be a coincidence maybe
very cool
so this got us thinking and this is just
kind of a fun
aside it's got us thinking why don't we
try
to take this laurence havoc model
and actually cook up our own model so
this is a model i built in matlab where
i've
manually enforced this
this symmetry and i've also enforced
that these are exact integer multiples
of five so the coefficients are 5 10 15
20 minus 25 30 35 40 minus 45 and so on
and so forth so this is a model
that is inspired by the lorenz havoc
model
but i just cooked this up from scratch
okay just as a state space system in
matlab
and what i do is i take that forcing
signal v15
measured from the real lorette system
and i force
this neighboring system with that with
that input
and this is the result so in white you
have the real lorentz system
and in red you have this neighboring
integer
valued system uh with the with the same
lorentz forcing
and this is just for me this is kind of
mind-blowing you have
this system there's no reason to think
that you can get lorentz dynamics from
this
highly structured integer dynamical
system
linear model just nuts right but if you
force this with the
the forcing that lorenz is experiencing
you get
beautifully the attractor switching the
dynamics on the attractor i mean it's
not perfect
which but it's way better than i would
have expected it's pretty amazing
what you capture of the real laurent
system from this highly idealized
integer structured model
so not sure what the connection is
honestly couldn't tell you
how to interpret the fact that they're
integer valued
that there's this alternating structure
but i just had to share it because it's
it's really cool all right uh thank you
very much
you